atenção seu desodorante pode estar
aumentando os níveis de alumínio no seu
corpo recentemente avalia aqui um
paciente com nível de alumínio no sangue
de 24,6 MG porl acima do valor máximo
você sabia que o uso de deodorant comuns
pode contribuir pro acúmulo de alumínio
no organismo o alumínio é um metal que
em excesso ele se acumula em vários
tecidos como cérebro e ossos e aumenta o
risco de vários problemas neurológicos
várias doenças crônicas muitos odorantes
do dia a dia esses anti transpirantes
eles utilizam Saas de alumínio para
bloquear o sol mas isso pode ter
consequências sérias paraa sua saúde
além dos desodorantes o alumínio está
presente em panelas alimentos
industrializados e até na água é
importante ficar atento às Fontes
ocultas desse metal no seu dia a dia
altos níveis de alumínio no organismo
pode trazer muitos prejuízos uma das
principais preocupações é a possível
Associação com doenças
neurodegenerativas a mais famosa de
todos a demência de Alzheimer isso
porque o alumínio ele pode se acumular
no tecido cerebral embora a relação
cause efeito ainda não esteja
completamente estabelecida ainda tem
dúvidas ainda tem questionamentos vários
estudos sugerem que a exposição a esse
metal alumínio pode contribuir pro
comprometimento mental cognitivo perda
de memória Além disso o alumínio pode
afetar a saúde dos Ossos porque ele
interfere na mineralização o processo de
agregar minerais no osso isso aumenta o
risco de osteoporose e também de
fraturas E também o uso do Alumínio vai
sobrecarregar os rins diminuindo a
eliminação de toxinas e agravando
problemas nos rins que já existiam
pré-existentes por isso é muito
importante é fundamental diminuir
minimizar a exposição a alumínio no
nosso dia a dia e para isso temos que
optar por produtos Livres desse metal e
adotar hábitos que promovam a
desintoxicação do organismo então para
reduzir a exposição opte por
desodorantes que não tenham alumínio
evite cozinhar em utensílios de alumínio
inclua na dieta alimentos que vão ajudar
a eliminar metais pesados o caso do
coentro e a clorela o uso do Silício
orgânico pode ser muito útil para
eliminar o alumínio do organismo quer
saber mais sobre marcas de desodorantes
que não contém alumínio Basta dar uma
olhada na legenda e não se esqueça de
Compartilhar esse vídeo com alguém que
Precisa dessas informações um grande
abraço um beijo no seu coração Você é
fera